ah
cuando charles darwin llegó a chile a
bordo del beagle al llegar al norte de
este país propuso que era un lugar donde
nada podría ser existir la primera vista
pareciera que eso podría ser así el
desierto de atacama es por lejos el
desierto más antiguo y más seco del
mundo en muchas ocasiones
nosotros hemos medido la humedad
relativa la este es cierto y hemos
encontrado típicamente las horas de la
tarde que la humedad relativa cabe a
cero
es por estas razones que el desierto de
atacama es considerado uno de los
mejores modelos análogos de marte en la
tierra además el desierto de atacama
recibe uno de los mayores niveles de
radiación ultravioleta en todo el globo
terrestre esa zona que indica ahí de
color blanco está indicando valores
mayores a 18 muchísimo más altos que la
escala que va de entre 0 y dense es que
nos indica cuándo debemos protegernos de
la radiación ultravioleta es por esa
razón es cierto que cuando uno va al
desierto de atacama en realidad es como
ir a marte están brutalmente extremos
sin embargo yo lo que he visto a través
de mi investigación es exactamente
opuesto lo que alguna vez alguien dijo
habiendo encontrado fantásticos ejemplos
de cómo la vida ha sido capaz de
adaptarse a este fantástico lugar pero
para eso hay que saber dónde buscar y en
muchas ocasiones hay que usar un
microscopio para ver lo que está ahí
toda la vida en la tierra requiere agua
para poder sobrevivir y es por eso que
la nasa cuando se decidió a explorar
marte dijo bueno tiene sentido entonces
buscar las evidencias de agua como una
primera aproximación para luego ir a sus
lugares y tratar de buscar evidencias de
vida
entonces yo dije bueno sigamos entonces
las mismas estrategias pero esta vez en
el desierto atacama explorando como la
vida es capaz de adaptarse a la extrema
falta de agua para eso partí en la
cordillera de la costa de este desierto
y empezó avanzar hacia los valles ver
arios que están en su interior
en la cordillera en la costa típicamente
la vida sobrevive a partir de las
neblinas costeras que ocurren en estos
sectores y además a partir del rocío
marino en el recipiente las bases son
las fuentes de agua en esta región esto
explica cierto que muchas veces la vida
se encuentre al interior de cavernas que
son alimentadas cual estás rossi 2
marino y neblina siendo estas un
verdadero refugio para la vida y sabemos
que hay cavernas y en marte por lo que
estimamos que podrían haber formas de
vida allí incluso nosotros usar tales
cavernas como nuestros primeros hogar de
hogares del planeta rojo
más adentro la vida también sigue en
este caso dependiendo de las neblinas
costeras y típicamente se ubica bajo
cristales de yeso o de cuarzo ya que son
translúcidos a la luz solar porque ahí
la vida fotosintética es capaz de
prosperar nuevamente como única fuente
de agua las neblinas que ocupan estos
sectores típicamente las horas de la
noche más adentro sí que ya ingresamos
los valles y operarios del desierto por
el cual el atacama es conocido y es ahí
es donde se reencuentra en algunas las
regiones más secas del planeta
sólo en dos ocasiones la nasa fue con el
objetivo específico de buscar vida en
marte que fueron las menciones de kings
o de una sonda es terrestre llegar al
medio del desierto de atacama es tan
seco que la conclusión sería esa que no
hay vida en el planeta tierra es esa si
el lugar que estamos investigando en ese
entonces la lanza ya ha propuesto esta
región en el desierto yungay como la más
seca del desierto atacaba pero yo sabía
que eso no era así porque había visto
neblinas y nubes en esa zona por lo
tanto colocamos sensores tu madre la
tira en distintos lugares del desierto y
encontramos tres lugares que eran mucho
más secos que nunca y siendo maría elena
azul por lejos el más seco de todos
permítanme nuevamente decirles que están
secos en estos lugares fíjense que
cuando uno escapaba a un metro de
profundidad y colocaba nuestros sensores
uno encontraba una humedad relativa en
el tiempo invariable siempre igual de
sólo un 13% como comparación esta noche
en valladolid tranquilamente vamos a
llegar a un 85 por ciento de humedad
relativa
mostrando que efectivamente este era uno
de los lugares más secos de la tierra
eso es lo que explica además que si
nosotros comparaban nuestros datos con
lo que estaba ocurriendo en marte uno
veía que en ocasiones mariaelena era
igual o incluso más seco de marte lo que
nos decía que el punto de vista de la
disponibilidad de agua al parecer no era
un limitante para la vida ni en la
tierra ni en el planeta rojo tampoco
uno quedaría que en estas zonas uno no
debiera encontrar nada de vida como lo
decía darwin sin embargo en el marco de
nuestra investigaciones encontramos al
menos 22 tipos de bacterias distintas en
estos lugares es en realidad que
teníamos hasta entonces pero el 2015
llegaron las lluvias ya en unas
ocasiones que llamó a nuestros sitios de
investigación empezamos a ver lagunas a
uno y otro lado del camino y nosotros
sabíamos que había llovido un poco antes
en esta zona en lluvias muy inusuales
para esta región pero no pensamos que
esta laguna era en efectos de las
lluvias y pensamos más bien que eran
lagunas es cierto causadas por la
actividad minera que es bastante
frecuente en esta zona y simplemente
seguimos nuestro camino pero en el año
2017 nuevamente hubo estos muy raros
eventos de lluvia y en esta ocasión
vimos con laguna en esta región
extremadamente seca en que la nasa había
reportado que en la región de yungay
y una esperaría a cierto que la lluvia
en esta región ese día residía como maná
del cielo en ciertos regiones tan secas
que pudiera beber agua en abundancia
pero curiosamente encontramos que el
caso era exactamente lo opuesto
encontramos que en estas regiones es
tóxica para la vida ya había aniquilado
al menos el 70 por ciento de las
especies microbianas que están presente
en estos suelos esto se debe porque
estas formas de vida microbiana son
extremadamente eficientes para para
capturar retener y usar la poca agua
disponible en la zona por lo que en
presencia de una gran cantidad de agua
disponible en forma repentina
simplemente no saben cómo lidiar con
esta agua y empiezan a inflarse como
verdaderos globos hasta reventar y morir
me creerán que incluso alguien es de
eeuu escribió un poema respecto de los
estrellados titulada las lluvias
asesinas
y eso es bien importante porque otros
investigadores notaron que los últimos
diez años ha estado lloviendo en atacama
como nunca antes registrado en el tiempo
lo que ven aquí en el mapa en color azul
son las zonas donde han tenido en exceso
comparado con los registros anteriores y
esto creemos que es uno de los
insospechados e inesperados efectos del
cambio climático global generado por el
hombre así como vendes actos en uno y
otro lugar del mundo lo que está
ocurriendo en los casos de recibos
catacamas está lloviendo más ya
aniquilando las muy adaptadas formas de
vida que hemos encontrado y eso
normalmente parte cierto por la base en
cierto de que darwin dijo en algún
momento es que aquí nada podría
sobrevivir sobrevivir en estos lugares
sin embargo nosotros hemos visto que es
exactamente lo contrario y esto partió
en respecto a los cuatro cambios que
están ocurriendo preocupante en el
desierto debido a la extracción minera a
gran escala que existe en estas regiones
que además utilizan mucha agua y para
una vida de escala fíjense que esto que
está ahí es sólo uno de los muchos
camiones que estas minas utilizan y esto
ha generado no solamente problemas en
los lugares donde se extrae esa agua que
son típicamente en las fuentes que están
en la cordillera los grandes sino que
además que hace se conecta a toda esa
agua altamente tóxica después de los
procesos productivos en lugares donde
tienes que descartarlos entonces es una
problemática que hasta hoy día todavía
no puede ser completamente resuelta
este equipo de allí es el río lohan que
es el único río capaz de cruzar las
zonas más áreas del desierto atacama y
productos justamente esta excesiva
extracción de agua no hace mucho el
ruido casi se secó por completo y
fíjense que solamente gracias a la ayuda
de los científicos locales y el gobierno
de chile que una especie de ranita que
sólo vive en estos sectores y en una
medida in extremis fueron todas
recogidas y llevadas al zoológico de
santiago la capital de chile es a 1600
kilómetros distancia para evitar su
completa extinción
luego viene una cosa muy curiosa que
algunas de las soluciones que han sido
planteadas para combatir el cambio
climático global como la masificación de
los ricos no eléctricos que como ustedes
saben requiere de una batería especial
con litio resulta que dónde están las
unas las plantas de extracción más
conocidas de litio en el mundo en el
salar del desierto atacama y existe para
nuevamente una gran preocupación de lo
que era masiva extracción de litio y el
uso de agua que se requiere para eso
está teniendo en ecosistemas como el que
ven ahí en el cual es antes solamente
tenían un interés turístico por lo
mismas características de 7 otra cama
por la ausencia de nubes también se
están estableciendo grandes proyectos
para poder utilizar la energía solar una
fuente energía limpia cierto en los
lugares que justamente nosotros estamos
estudiando y el programa normalmente en
el mismo se están estableciendo en
aquella zona ciertos hombres por de
facto se dice es que aquí no hay nada
que proteger como dijo a alguien y como
nosotros hemos demostrado que es el caso
puesto entonces nos trae el problema de
que hacemos con la protección de estos
lugares porque una bonita
un par de bacterias por aquí y por allá
en estas zonas tan secas fíjense que
entre las especies que hemos encontrado
en estos suelos se encuentran especies
del género streptomyces la suela la
estreptomicina que son típicamente las
prácticas que son capaces de producir
antibióticos y deben tener también en
mente el alarmante aumento de algunas
bacterias que son tolerante exacto con
los antibióticos creados por el hombre y
descubiertos por el hombre entonces no
nos podemos dar el lujo excepto de tajar
con distintos proyectos a aquellos
lugares donde están justamente aquellas
especies que nos podrían permitir
solucionar hasta los problemas más aún
más críticos se estima que el 70 por
ciento de la superficie de los
continentes se va a tornar mucho más
árida en el tiempo y por lo tanto
nuevamente no nos podemos dar el lujo
cierto de descuidar aquellos lugares
donde están justamente las bases
genéticas que nos permitirían cierto
lidiar por los cambios requeridos que
tenemos que hacer frente al cambio
climático global y es por esta razón
ciertos de ellos recientemente visto
bueno algo que hay que hacer y voy a
dedicar parte importante de mi tiempo
justamente no solamente para
es cierto sino que también intentar
protegerlo esto ya lo logra en dos
ocasiones puntuales anteriores
justamente uno de los lugares en los
cuales nosotros habíamos descubiertos
vidas microbianas en una de estas
cavernas de la cordillera de la costa
después de los a nuestros hallazgos dio
pie a que toda esa zona se protegiera
por la corporación nacional forestal de
chile y sea ahora declarada una reserva
natural es gracias al trabajo nosotros
que eso se logró también debido a los
trabajos que estábamos haciendo en este
increíble salar que también está en las
zonas más áreas del desierto también por
los hallazgos que nosotros empezamos a
publicar en la prensa cierto también
fuera declarada un lugar de patrimonio y
de interés para todos sin embargo esa
tarea hasta ahí hasta ahí puedo llegar
yo porque además yo quiero dar el
ejemplo esto es lo que está ocurriendo
en el desierto como un ejemplo y una voz
de alerta en lo que está ocurriendo a
otros lugares los cambios que se están
planteando para mejorar el mundo tienen
que alguna forma ser por ustedes
críticamente y rigurosamente examinados
para ver que efectivamente quizá alguna
de estas alternativas tenemos que
repensar las para que todos los cambios
que estamos planteando sean para todos
los actores involucrados sustentables y
que para todos pueden llegar a tener un
mundo mejor gracias
[Aplausos]